phoenix persönlich mein heutiges ist
deutschlands derzeit wohl bedeutendsten
schriftsteller ferdinand von schirach
von beruf ist er eigentlich rechtsanwalt
und es ist ihm gelungen die zentralen
fragen der justiz gut und böse wer wird
was zum täter zur literatur zu machen
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix vielen
dank dass ich hier sind ja wir treffen
uns hier im café einstein in berlin sie
sind glaube ich häufiger hier schreiben
sie auch im café also ein wunderbares
kaffee und ja ich schreibe auch im café
finden sie die situation in einem café
sehr angenehm weil man also teil der
welt ist aber man muss nicht daran
teilnehmen also man kann sozusagen da
sitzen und beobachten und hat einen
aufgeklappten laptops herrlich cafés ein
wunderbar zu sprechen und passenderweise
heißt ihr neuestes buch auch kaffee und
zigaretten über kaffee haben wir gerade
schon gesprochen welche bedeutung haben
zigaretten für sie also einmal ist es
gut dass dass es ganz schwer für mich
ist ohne zigaretten zu schreiben man
gewöhnt sich das irgendwann an und dann
wird das du so ein teil des schreibens
und zum anderen sind zigaretten deshalb
ganz gut weil sie die perfekte trug ist
und weil sie überhaupt keine
befriedigung verschaffen und man einfach
immer mehr nehmen muss und auf die
befriedigung wartet die nicht eintritt
und das dritte ist das ist ein bisschen
ernst zigaretten sind zu einem momentum
mori also eine dauernde erinnerung an
den tod und das ist mit dem schreiben
also beim schreiben so ein bisschen
übereinstimmen
eigentlich sind sie hätten ja aus der
öffentlichkeit verbannt man darf in
aller regel in restaurants in cafés
nicht mehr rauchen sie machen das
gegenteil sie heben die zigaretten auf
den titel ihres buches sie bieten in
diesem buch auch ein ganzes kapitel
deutschlands berühmtestem raucher
dass helmut schmidt und sie sagen ich
glaube helmut schmidt das ist der ideale
raucher ja genau der ist deshalb der
ideale also einmal passen sie schön wir
gebraucht hat und wir können ja helmut
späth alles mögliche sagen gutes und
schlechtes aber das mit dem rauchen war
toll weil er weil er das zu einer
kunstform erhoben hat er hat dann in
manchen talkshows kann man das immer
noch sehen wenn man die auf youtube oder
wo auch immer anschaut dass er eine
zigarette ganz langsam anzündete und
alleine dadurch entstand eine pause und
dann zucker den rauch einatmete den über
seinen gesprächspartner hinweg und das
war jedes mal derselbe effekt dass alle
kurz still waren und er die bühne für
sich hat das war konnte das richtig toll
und dann hat er später als wir ihn zum
elder statesman gemacht haben und ihn
nur noch bewundert haben hat er ja auch
in theatern und überall geraucht einfach
so und bekamen jedes mal eine fülle von
anzeigen die eingestellt worden
ich fand es ganz toll jetzt hatte helmut
schmidt ich glaube vier bypässe einen
herzinfarkt würde mir ja eher zu rufen
helmut las dass auch und seien sie
schreiben in ihrem buch im gegenteil
dass sie angst hatten dass einer der
ärzte ihm das rauchen ausreden würde
wieso das also zwei dinge dazu zum einen
war es so dass die erste ihm gesagt
haben er muss weiter rauchen
irgendwann war der körper so an das
nikotin gewöhnen dass das aufhören das
rauchen sofort zum tod geführt hätte und
das andere war es ist so ein bisschen
komplizierter wir leben ja in einer welt
in der praktisch alles schon verboten
und geregelt ist also ich habe
neulich auf einem flug nach münchen
durch gezählt wie viele verbote man
insgesamt bekommt ich bin auf 46 bis zu
lande umgekommen es geht ja los vom
tisch hochklappen bis verstauen sie ihr
gepäck da und da und nicht dort und
setzen sie aufrecht und und machen sie
die jalousien hoch und alles mögliche
was übrigens alles gar keine rolle
gespielt wenn das flugzeug abstürzt und
und so geht das weiter und wenn es dann
solche menschen gibt die sich weigern
das zu tun und nun dafür war helmut
schmidt ihm mit dem rauchen ein ausdruck
finde ich das sehr sympathisch weil
unsere unsere welt eng wird dies ist
rauchen das muss man natürlich sagen
ganz blöde ja es schädigt ein das ist
vollkommen vorbild das ist wie ein rotes
fleisch essen und alles mögliche andere
aber das war genau das tolle an helmut
schmidt dass sie das überhaupt nicht
interessiert hat helmut schmidt hat ein
einweg feuerzeug benutzt hat die
zigaretten direkt aus der packung geholt
sie haben das ja hier schon liegen edles
feuerzeug silber etwa was hat das für
eine bedeutung für sie also bei schmidt
war das glaube ich zu teil seines
sozialdemokratischen ansehen sie hätte
glaube ich unmöglich ein silbernes etui
benutzen können das war genauso wie
diese alberne prinz heinrich wird zudem
auch nicht gestanden hat und
gleichzeitig diese diese fantastisch
aussehenden anzüge also das war glaube
ich einfach so ein entgegenkommen seiner
wähle ich finde ich finde so die diese
diese accessoires wie so einig wie das
ist so ein bisschen ein schutz vor der
hässlichkeit der welt haben und man
spielt und man muss die schrecklichen
bilder nicht angucken die auf den
packungen und es gibt diese hässlichen
kleinen bildchen die keiner mag und die
glaube ich auch nicht verbrauchen
abhalten
die nur furchtbar sind und und wie
umgeben uns ja eigentlich wenn es nicht
zu gerechnet wie es immer mit solchen
sachen ja wir ziehen uns ordentlich an
um geschützt zu sein oder wir haben
bestimmte riten die wir einhalten um die
welt nicht zu nahe kommen zu lassen und
und diese zigarettenetuis oder
fahrzeuggröße du hast dass es so eine
idee von es nützt nichts bei mir bei ich
sie dauernd verliere also gibt ganz
wenige sachen die ich nicht verlieren
das sind wie zum beispiel das schon ganz
altes aber bei vielen dingen ist also
fahrzeuge sind furchtbar die geschichte
über das rauchen oder bei helmut schmidt
ist eine der geschichten anekdoten die
sie da hat sich eigentlich rauchen hier
stört sie haben sich erkundigt
der hausherr das café sagt zettl und es
stört sie auch nicht da aber nicht
aufgestellt
kaffee und zigaretten eine ganz
einzigartig eigentümliche mischung von
von persönlichen erinnerungen und von
geschichten die auf den ersten blick so
nebeneinander stehen ohne dass sie so
viel miteinander zu tun haben
die eine geschichte helmut schmidt
hammer erwähnt eine andere geschichte
die mir aufgefallen ist da berichten sie
über die drei rechtsanwälte chilli maler
und ströbele die alle an einem punkt
etwas gemeinsames haben sie haben alle
drei terroristen der raf verteidigt aber
dann hatten sie einen ganz
unterschiedlichen lebenswegen ja also
ich hatte das glück dass ich als ganz
junger anwalt in der ehemaligen kanzlei
von otto sie anfangen konnte und habe
mich zu mit ihm beschäftigt mit mit dem
wasser dargestellt und chili ist
tatsächlich so einer der
interessantesten figuren dieser zeit
gewesen und auch als strafverteidiger
war unglaublich interessant weil er weil
er etwas gemacht hat was es sonst nur
noch selten gibt er hat zwar seine
mandanten verteidigt mit allem was man
so als anwalt ordentlich machen uns aber
er hat gleichzeitig immer das recht
verteidigt und das war damals notwendig
also die bundesrepublik in dieser zeit
war ihr relativ unsicher man man traf
die entscheidung alle neu
war dem terrorismus stand man etwas
hilflos sogar gegenüber und und wussten
nicht ganz genau wie man sich verhalten
sollte und es gibt viel schief und und
chili also geprägt durch die
nachkriegszeit durch die verluste die er
in seiner familie erlitten hat in der ns
zeit begann als einer der ersten mit
großer konsequenz das recht zu
verteidigen
die würde des menschen und das war
sozusagen sein großes thema und viele
leute verstanden später liegt dass
ausgerechnet diese terroristen
verteidiger innenminister wurde und
dabei was genau das gleiche nur mit
anderen mitteln auch als innenminister
hatte das recht verteidigt und und das
recht als als sozusagen den haupt inhalt
eines lebens ist toll als figur so wie
sie das jetzt sehr schildern kann ich
den lebensweg von otto schily
nachvollziehen wie viel schwerer
nachzuvollziehen ist der lebensweg von
von horst mahler ja der ist mit der raf
in den untergrund gegangen ist dann zu
zwölf jahren gefängnis verurteilt worden
inzwischen ist er ganz rechts außen
gelandet und verteidigt oder leugnet den
holocaust
können sie das begreifen also es gibt
glaube ich keinen größeren denkbaren
unterschied wie zwischen schily und
ströbele auf der einen seite und maler
auf der anderen
mahler hat auch wenn ich das richtig sie
nicht das recht verteidigt zu den war
von anfang an eine hochpolitische figur
und und solidarisierte sich mit seinen
mandanten was man als anwalt niemals
machen darf sondern das verhältnis
zwischen anwalt und mandant muss immer
von allergrößter distanz geprägt sein
und da gab es eine eine merkwürdige
situation maler wurde vorurteil zu
dieser hohen strafe zwölf jahren zwölf
jahre und den unterschied zwischen den
charakteren von von schily und ströbele
sieht man auch daran dass ströbele sich
der freundliche mensch der gute mensch
sozusagen um die familie von mahler
gekümmert hat und chili brachte ihm
hegel und zwar die gesamtausgabe ins
gefängnis und ich kann das heißt dass
nur aus erzählungen aber es sollen so
gewesen sein dass dann male zehn jahre
lang nichts anderes als hebel lars und
ich glaube es ist einfach so wenn man
zehn jahre hegel liest wird man in
irgendeiner weise extrem und und es ist
dabei vollkommen egal ob das ganz links
oder ganz rechtsextremist das liegt
daran dass die philosophen zu dieser
zeit zu geschlossenes system hat und
hebel hatte wahrscheinlich eines der
alle geschlossen und maler verfing sich
darin und und dann spielt es keine rolle
mehr ob man links und rechts ist es gibt
noch einen weiteren punkt
mahler war ja muss man auch sagen
brillant ja und und hatte ein wirklich
toll funktionieren das gehirn und wenn
man wenn man diesen typus sich anschaut
des kalten juristen den gab es in der
bundesrepublik
er ist leider sehr häufig und dieser
callte jurist der der sozusagen sich
auch in den verästelungen des rechts
verfängt und die menschlichkeit dabei
vergisst das ist der typus maler
wir haben ja gerade erwähnt dass sie
ihre berufliche karriere als
rechtsanwalt begonnen haben in der
kanzlei von lotta schelin der ehemaligen
schüler schon raus und einer ihrer
ersten fälle war die verteidigung von
günter schabowski im
mauerschützenprozess wir erinnern uns
günter schabowski war der sprecher des
zentralkomitees der sed der auszusehen
die mauer geöffnet hat jetzt war der da
also angeklagt im mauerschützenprozess
was hat sie daran
hausgeräte gereizt ausgerechnet ihn zu
verteidigen
naja ich war also erstens war ich 29 und
das war der größte prozess der
nachkriegsgeschichte und so ein mandat
zu bekommen war natürlich dass alle
größte was man sie überhaupt vorstellen
konnte und dann fand ich abgesehen von
all diesen sachen fand ich den die
rechtsfragen dieses prozesses sehr
interessant also dass man muss sich das
so vorstellen
der bundesgerichtshof und der
europäische gerichtshof die haben das ja
alles am schluss entschieden und wie es
ausgegangen das weiß man aber die die
fragen am anfang waren schon interessant
nämlich die frage ist kann man diesen
mitgliedern des politbüros die sehr spät
und das politbüro kam vorwerfen dass sie
nicht früher die mauer geöffnet haben
und den schießbefehl aufgehoben haben
und das ist ein bisschen ein
merkwürdiger vorwurf weil man kann ihn
nur etwas vorwerfen wenn sie auch die
möglichkeit haben es zu tun und das ist
bei der innerdeutschen grenze oder bei
der mauer schwierig gewesen weil ja
eigentlich dass nicht die mauer zwischen
deutschland und deutschland wahr sondern
es war die mauer zwischen osten und
westen
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
selbst wenn das gesamte politbüro auf
gestanden hätte wäre und gesagt wir
machen ihm auf dass die russen das
zugelassen also juristisch eine komplexe
fragen so ungefähr ging eure
verteidigung stellen würden sie
eigentlich jeden verteidigen
es gibt fälle die ich nicht verteidigen
würden also ich würde auf gar keinen
fall irgendetwas im rechtsradikalen
milieu verteidigen
das ist mir so zuwider dass ich
hier kann ich wieder anfangen und ich
würde ich würde bei kindesmissbrauch
nicht verteidigen weil ich gar nichts
von kindern verstehe also ich weiß
einfach nicht wann die lügen und wann
sie die wahrheit sagen und und man muss
als verteidiger dann aber ein kind
befragen können und jetzt stellen sich
immer vor das kind berichtet die
wahrheit und wird dann noch mal gefragt
ist schwierig für mich also das würde
ich nicht machen und ansonsten gibt es
ziemlich wenig sagen wie ich nicht
verteilt würde jetzt warte ja ein sehr
erfolgreicher anwalt der eine oder
andere benutzt sogar das wort vom
prominenten anwalt und dann mit 45 haben
sie ihrem leben eine ganz neue wende
gegeben und haben begonnen bücher zu
schreiben
sehr erfolgreich das würden glaube ich
viele leute gerne machen mit 45 einfach
noch mal ganz von vorne anfangen
wissen sie ein bisschen ist es ja so
dass wir dass unser leben nur in der
rückschau einen sinn gewinnt nicht in
dem moment in dem wir etwas tun wird
also wir durch unsere erzählung gewinnt
es hin
und mir kommt das ein bisschen heute vor
als wäre diese zeit als anwalt ein
zwischenschritt gewesen und das
schreiben das eigentlich ich habe mit 13
mein erstes theaterstück geschrieben
ein unglaublich schlechtes stück
übrigens eine adaption von den drei
musketieren und es ging hauptsächlich um
die fechtszenen und die dialoge bahn
absolute nebensache
aber damals wurde mir gesagt also dass
das schritt stelle bettelarm sind und in
kellern boden und an lungenentzündung
sterben und so mutig war ich nicht und
und dass zu viele jahrhunderte lang bei
uns juristen in der familie gab lag das
danach und im jura denn natürlich das
strafrecht weil ob der von dem geld
bekommt hat mir aber nie interessiert
und damit sein leben zu verbringen
vernichten
sehr langweilig und ich finde aber so
ganz froh dass es dann mit dem schreiben
geklappt hat und heute fühle ich mich
wohl damit ja ich weiß nicht ob das in
noch mal zehn jahren wieder irgendwas
anderes würde es ist ja gelungen
zentralen fragen der juristerei zur
literatur zum dort greift mal eine frage
heraus die sie immer wieder
thematisieren werde warum zum täter dann
kann jeder zum verbrecher werden steckt
es in jedem von uns ja das glaube ich
schon
also das ist also wir müssen uns das
verständnis also ich rede jetzt nicht
von staatsverbrechen oder von von
verbrechen die die die kalt geplant sind
sondern von dem was du
zwischenmenschlich passiert und da ist
es so dass das oft nur ein quantitativer
unterschied ist ein qualitativer also
wenn sie abends nach hause gehen und es
war wieder so eine blöde sendung mit zu
einem blöden schriftsteller und sind so
etwas wütend und und motzen ihre frau
ein und werden laut mit ihr ja dann ist
das tatsächlich eine form von gewalt ja
eine ganz kleine form von gewalt aber
das ist gewalt und von dem laut werden
und dem anschreiben bis zu dem ersten
schubsen ist es nur ein winziger schritt
und von dem von dem schubsten bis zur
ersten ohrfeige ist es wieder nur ein
kleiner schritt und so geht es weiter
und man und am schluss gibt es kommt das
messer ins spiel und in die axt oder
oder irgendetwas anderes oder mann
schubste man die treppe runter und diese
diese unterschiede sind graduell also
das ist tatsächlich ein haken machen die
umstände den menschen zum verbrecher
oder gibt es schon den freien willen
dass jeder die entscheidung trifft ich
tue das und ich tue es eben nicht es
gibt beides also das schließt sich nicht
aus
ich glaube dass ist zu zu einem ganz
großen teil die umstände sind ob wir
glück haben und so durchkommen oder ob
wir pech haben und und das eis unter uns
bricht und
wir ins kalte sinken aber natürlich
haben wir einen freien willen es gibt ja
hirnforscher die sagen wir haben keinen
freien willen und ist es sozusagen
vorher bestimmt was immer mag sein
wissenschaftlich aber wir dürfen nicht
dran glauben ja wenn wir das tun müssen
wir unsere gesellschaft sofort aufgeben
wir können niemanden mehr für
irgendetwas verantwortlich machen kein
politiker kein verbrechen nichts mehr
also ich glaube es gibt einen freien
willen und sonst tun wir so als würde
das umgeben
tatsächlich ist aber trotzdem die
umstände ja also eine verkettung
unglücklicher umstände führten der
riegel und wenn man in der rückschau
einem verbrechen anschaut dann sind das
meistens unglücklicher umstände
dann gibt es natürlich noch einen großen
anteil der vielen vielen also zeitlich
viel weiter von der tat weg ist die
irgendwo in der kindheit begründet ist
ich würde gern noch mal auf ihrem buch
zu sprechen kommen sie haben wir im
vorfeld ein paar zeilen dazu geschickt
unter anderem haben sie geschrieben
es ist ein buch über die einsamkeit ja
sie sind sie einsam sind wir alle eins
an
ja also das glaube ich schon also dass
sie einsam sind und dass wir alles für
alle einsam sind dass sich auch unser
bin zumindest ein bisschen
wir sitzen jetzt hier so ordentlichen
anzügen also ihr anzug ist zumindest
ordentlich vergessen sie aber und sie
bemühen sich so teil diese dieser welt
zu sein und und sind das meistens auch
aber wenn sie abends im bett liegen und
und der tag klingt so aus denn dann
merken sie dass sie doch alleine sind
mit mit all ihren fehlern und im
nachdenken und ihre nierenproblemen und
so weiter und diese diese einsamkeit
nimmt meines erachtens zu
ja also
das liegt also zum einen so an sachen
die wir ja da und spricht zu namen der
sozialen netzwerke dass die leute sich
mehr mit ihrem elektronischen equipment
beschäftigen als mit dem nächsten
menschen das sehen sie in jedem café das
ist ein fünf leute an einem tisch alles
staaten auf ihr handy
ich habe vor zwei tagen gelesen dass 30
prozent der leute nur noch mit dem handy
sich sms schicken oder chatten oder wie
es heißt und nicht mehr telefonieren
weil sie angst haben vor dem spontanen
gespräch ja das ist schon ein bisschen
erschreckend und in england wurde vor
kurzem einen ministerium für einsamkeit
gegründet weil so viele menschen
inzwischen allein in ihren wohnungen
leben
die familienverbände sind aufgelöst und
das was wir eigentlich als große
freiheit empfinden nämlich dass es das
wir fern sein können von unserer
großfamilie ist schrecklich diese ganzen
tanten und onkels und so weiter und um
sich zu haben wie es früher mal war
wir haben eigene wohnung und leben dort
relativ bequem drin aber das schafft
auch einsamkeit und ich glaube ein ein
kleiner trick gegen die einsamkeit ist
sich bewusst zu machen dass man auch
etwas einsam ist dann wird es irgendwie
besser wenn man immer denkt das geht
niemanden anderen so wie man es nur man
selbst hat dieses dann wird schwierig
das ist ihr bisher persönlichstes buch
man gewinnt den eindruck dass diese
einsamkeit schon bei ihnen als kind
angelegt was ich gestanden aus nach sehr
wohlhabenden bürgerlichen familien ich
verkürzt das mal viel viel haut viele
hausangestellte aber wenig menschliche
nähe
na ja das stimmt ein bisschen
auf der anderen seite war es ja bei
vielen in meiner generation ich bin also
64 geborenen und das war damals war man
nicht so wahnsinnig eng mit den kindern
die kinder waren da es war schön dass
sie da sind aber und man hatte jetzt
nicht diesen kontakt den eltern heute
mit ihren kindern haben dass mit ihnen
auf den spielplatz stunden lang gehen
und und die schaukel hin und her bewegen
dass das wäre bei uns zu schon
ausgeschlossen gewesen
die vorstellung alleine und es war ja
aber aber wissen sie es ist nicht so
dass es dass kinder das so empfinden ja
das tun wir auch erst im nachhinein
kinder haben keine adjektive für ihre
kinder die wir nie sagen ich habe eine
schöne kindheit gerade ich habe eine
schlimme gehen halt gerade kindheiten
sind sie ja alle erlebnisse sind ja wir
wissen ja gar nichts als kennt wir sehen
irgendetwas zum ersten mal er hat fast
alles sehen wir zuerst mal und bei mir
war es ruhig das war auf dem land und
und und es gab tatsächlich nicht sehr
viel und zwar alles sehr sehr langsam
und unglaublich langweilig ist passierte
einfach gar nichts und machte das aber
ganz gern
sie sind in dem buch sehr offen sich
schreiben auch darüber dass er mit 15
war es glaube ich einen
selbstmordversuch begangen haben ist
ihnen das sehr schwer gefallen da drüber
zu schreiben
natürlich dass es dass es furchtbar
darüber zu schreiben ja das ist auch
deshalb furchtbar also nicht dass
darüber schreiben ist furchtbar das geht
damit komme ich zurecht
das schlimme ist sozusagen das man eine
tür aufmacht und alle reinschauen können
ja das widerspricht beim lesen etwas auf
der anderen seite ist das so dass das
buch kann man nicht verstehen oder
könnte man je verstehen wenn ich das
nicht geschrieben habe das ist das ist
die erste geschichte und das ist der
grundton dieses buches und und das
wegzulassen dann hätte man am schluss zu
aufzugs musik und
gebrauchskunst und und es wäre
langweilig also es gibt so ein wenn man
ordentlich schreiben will und seinen
sachen so erzählen möchte dann dann gibt
es schon so ein anspruch auf
literarische wahrheit ja dass keine
dokumentation und es man kann jetzt
nicht so alles ganz genau nachvollziehen
aber aber es muss schon stimmen ist es
muss eine literarische wahrheit sein
sonst hat es keinen sinn zu wahrheit und
ihrer geschichte gehört auch dass hier
ein sehr belasteten namen tragen
ihr großvater baldur von schirach war
reichsjugendführer im ns regime
er war der bauleiter später von wien und
im buch erzählt sie auch eine sehr
bewegende geschichte wie sie eine
ukrainische anwälten treffen deren
großeltern mutmaßlich durch das ton
ihres großvaters ums leben kamen ja
genau wie schwer fällt ihnen die
auseinandersetzung mit ihrem großvater
also das ist so ein teil einfach von
meinem leben geworden ja ich würde ich
habe sehr früh also in so einer familie
wie meine ist natürlich alles öffentlich
ja da gibt es nicht den moment dass
irgendjemand auf die auf den dachboden
geht und dort die ss-uniform des
großvaters findet und vollkommen
erschreckt ist sondern bei uns war alles
öffentlich bekannte figur gegessen ich
darf mal einen haken
also ihr großvater war einer der
angeklagten in den prozessen wurde zu 20
jahren gefängnis verurteilt und kam dann
1966 und und deswegen beschäftigt man
sich sehr früh damit oder ich
beschäftige mich sehr früh damit und
habt und im studium
die die prozessakten die protokolle der
nürnberger prozesse gelesen und und dass
es dann so ein teil des lebens dass man
immer wieder darüber nachdenken
nun ist es so ich habe ein ganzes buch
darüber geschrieben der fall collini wo
diese fragen der nachkriegszeit vor
allen dingen behandelt worden sind
und letztlich ist es so und zu dem
ergebnis kommt man nach einem leben der
auseinandersetzung dass das natürlich
die schuld diese generation und die
schuld meines großvaters die schuld
meines großvaters ist nicht meine schuld
das ist wenn man dem
bundesverfassungsgericht folgt ist es so
dass das schult persönliche
verantwortung bedeutet persönliche
vorwerk barkeit wobei es um das
persönlich gehe aber die schuld ist eine
sache und die verantwortung die man
trägt mit zu einem namen eine ganz
andere und diese verantwortung muss man
ernst nehmen und die geht auch nicht weg
also das ist so tatsächlich teil meines
lebens geworden und es ist ja auch
vernünftig das immer wieder zu betonen
und immer wieder sich dagegen zu stellen
und auch diese anfänge die wir jetzt
haben mit dieser festlichen afd da muss
man sich dagegen stellen da bleibt einem
nichts anderes übrig
mit seinem namen sie haben sinngemäß
gesagt die auseinandersetzung mit den
taten und räten meines großvaters haben
mich zu dem gemacht was ich heute bin ja
man kann mit diesen verbrechen und
diesen diesem furchtbaren setzen die da
in wien gesagt hat zum beispiel so ein
satz wie zum beispiel dass das die
vertreibung der juden
sein beitrag zur kultur europas eine
blase so wirklich geistliches dummes
scheußliches zeug und vor allen dingen
aber natürlich nicht nicht die sätze
sondern auch die taten er war
verantwortlich für die deportation der
juden aus wien und letztlich auch für
die morde an ihn und und natürlich ist
es so dass man dass man immer dass das
wird was ein was einen in seinem leben
beschäftigt und bei mir war es eben die
wut und die scham über solche sätze die
mich geprägt haben dass es ist ganz klar
es geht nicht anders
sie haben es gerade erwähnt dass sie die
geschichte von ihnen und ihrem großvater
in ziemlich abgewandelte form auch
verarbeitet haben in ihrem roman der
fall collini das kommt demnächst in die
kinos der fall collini in der hauptrolle
elias m'barek ab 18 april im kino
vierter märz schon in den buchhandlungen
ihr buch kaffee und zigaretten das war
heute phoenix persönlich mit ferdinand
von schirach herzlichen dank dass ich da
sein dürfte
[Musik]